foreign
in the United States these days to be
fair China doesn't say great things
about the U.S either
the two big nations are stuck in a
geopolitical deadlock that is bad for
Progress to fight climate change
I'm a China sustainability policy
analyst and I have witnessed a clean
energy Revolution there that could mean
big things for the rest of the world
but it's become clear to me that if the
U.S continues to China as a threat the
desired translation will never happen at
the faster pace and a larger scale as
expected
we urgently need to Pivot from the
currently dismal relations and the reset
a construction rather than distract
foundation for Global clean energy
Revolution
thank you
let's take a look at the clean energy
manufacturing manufacturing because this
seems to be where the tension lies today
some U.S commentators said the best
chance was 10 years ago the second best
chance is now
the best chance was China's drive to
invest aggressively and ambitiously in
clean Technologies with the China make
2025 campaign
the outcome is massive deployment of
Clean Energy Solutions that established
China as a global leader in this
landscape
the U.S inflation reduction act in 2022
a climate law that pushes free
investments in domestic energy clean
energy production represents the second
best chance
the iea executive director fatsi vividly
call this Dynamic the beginning of a new
age of clean energy Manufacturing
a decade apart China and the U.S stand
at a different position along the global
value chain
while China is already in the second
second decade in transition the U.S is
just starting to take off
the recent data shows China provides the
77 percent of global batteries last year
and is right on track to lead all
nations in manufacturing Clean Energy
Products by 2013. China's investment has
also put it as Global leader leading
exporter of those Technologies Seoul
solar wind batteries you name it
my professional experience also tells me
that the U.S can learn a greater deal
from China's steadfast dedication to
push forward the clean energy transition
in some key ways
firstly China is re-energizing the
world's largest Energy System with
Renewables and smart grid infrastructure
and the U.S can adapt this with much
shorter learning curve and reduce the
costs
the first half of this year saws 34 of
China's electricity generated from
non-fossil fuels right on track to
deliver 39 by 2025 as has been planned
and aiming for 80 percent by 2035
between now and the 2035 China's
national Endeavors are focused on rapid
expansion of installations and also
consumption of clean energy in all
sectors you could imagine
in the meantime it's also dedicated to
enhancing great transfer transmission
and distribution system to accommodate
this growth of Renewables
even as China operates Tire system in
two different regulatory contests but
share the logic and also technicality
when designing and building a clean
smart netajira carbon emissions grid
system
China is also becoming a real Daredevil
in pioneering the development of 5G and
AI enabled power system and deploying
the high ultra high voltage Bridge
systems
supplemented by vehicle to grid
Technologies in order to accommodate the
rise of EVS
China's experience can provide an
invaluable reference or insight for the
U.S to decarbonize your own power system
secondly China is leading a global
campaign to increase solar usage
the social economic environmental model
deployed in China can help the U.S to
address climate Injustice challenge
domestically
solar energy is becoming the least cost
option for new electricity generation in
most part of the world today
the IE forecast an average annual solar
generation growth of 25 between 2022 and
2030 which is about the 10 times of the
current total Global installations in
order to achieve that zero carbon
emissions by mid-century
or to put another another way it is one
kilowatt solar installation per person
by 2030. that number stands today at a
10 as a 10 kilowatts globally
China is on its way to achieve 250
kilowatts by the end of this year
to bridge the gap a group of leading
Chinese universities and institutions
launched the China campaign advocating
one kilowatt solar installation per
person by 2013.
the strategy is real and also turning
that into a global campaign called the
solar light subplanet the strategy is to
really use solar installation as the
intervention point to explore how rural
energy transitioned in China can benefit
other U.N sustainability targets
on one side is causing its effective
one kilowatt solar insulation requires
five square meters of space and 500
dollars upfront investment to install
when completed it generates bring
electricity while avoiding carbon
emissions
and on the other side it also
demonstrates that co-benefits can be
created and maximized
energy transition can bring a new
investment and also pray to bring power
enable the group's opportunities
for instance food agriculture fishery
Energy Services tourism and other
Industries
China's experience uh definitely can be
very valuable for the U.S to think about
the solutions to address climate
Injustice
solar lights of planets is the ambition
it also offers colleagues in the United
States to work with peers from China and
other parts of the world to really
tackle the climate Injustice challenge
thirdly
China is mainstreaming circular economy
and transforming its Supply chains
zoning forces China the U.S together
with the EU can literally reset the
global supply chain
Softly on sustainability
China is a global manufacturing
Powerhouse its demand for raw materials
and critical methods is growing as
financially
as we all know the planet cannot
possibly afford the ecological
destruction from kodupu and in some
cases even six times the current input
of predicate metals to match the plant
energy transition
a circular economy offers a remedy to
decouple the growth from resource use
China is also well positioned to reset
its Supply chains with circularity at
the core
today China recycles more than 95
percent of nickel and Elysium
business communities have a big role to
play providing Solutions or answers to
what her losses remove what innovative
solutions reply but business models
actually to promote and very importantly
how to consolidate the global
partnership to work together to shift
our sustainable and circular Global
Supply Chain
which is why a group of Chinese
organizations
are working together kicking off a
China's secularity 100 initiative aiming
by 2030 to really find the pathways to
close the loop in recycling for critical
methods and also for the energy sector
is targeting at least 100 companies to
work together to find the alternative
pathways
China's practice can become a very
important reference for the United
States to make investment decisions to
and break the circularity now
so how do we jump start a new U.S China
partnership
while the two governments has already
should start with a revised narrative
one that is with good intention as well
as with the collaborative spirit
in the meantime the two Nations need to
assure the rest of the world that they
are really seriously and sincerely
working together to find their
alternative and rebuild partnership
one thing to keep in mind the client
region doesn't care about our
ideological divide rather it demands for
flattered reactions that deliver
outcomes
Corner in China as a national security
threat seems to claim that the U.S
rather than China is the legitimate and
trustworthy Global leader in this
transition
and yet as the world largest developed
the economy the U.S doesn't meet the bar
of what is budget of global leader
along the line it doesn't provide the
rest of the world with sufficient
accessible and affordable Clean Energy
Solutions know that they provide deliver
its Financial commitment to other
developing countries under the Paris
agreement
and China undoubtedly has to go a long
way too in rethinking it's a strategy
and a behavior in dealing with the US it
needs to make us efforts to convince the
world that it's not a threat but rather
a trusted partner willing and achievable
to work with the U.S to shift towards
collaborative partnership
let me leave this stage with some sort
of cautious optimism
my heart feels enlightened with media in
our two countries start to tell
different U.S China stories
treasury secretary yellen's China trip
last week went to violence Chinese
social media
the rainbow welcoming her Landing in
Beijing airport represents some hope and
also a new beginning of bilateral
relations
and her love for the wild mushroom soup
from guildan Province
literally gives me this kind of a worm
and also sweet human touch
and I have a message to Prime its own
way John Kerry who is coming to China
later this month
you know
the two governments have already
declared the quiet and number of joint
commitments and the collective actions
to fight the climate change
what's urgently needed now is a shared
Vision Nation aspiration wisdom and very
importantly are Compass to guide
everyone back on track to take a
collective absence and deliver the new
results
it seems to me that the master have
precondition for us all in order to keep
a sustainable future Within Reach thank
you
[Applause]